speaking of documenting things yes you
have been going through like so much and
it's amazing how much you're doing based
on how much you've been through you know
of course you know the world knows that
your mom still going through the still
going through brain cancer right and
that's something that you and Kevin and
everybody around you has been working on
and working with her tirelessly for how
long now it's gonna be three years in
August that's incredible
yeah God God thankfully yeah given us a
lot of time and at the same time what a
year ago maybe a little more a year and
a half ago yeah you find out that you
have a brain tumor mm-hmm and have to
get it removed and go through so while
you're working with your mom going
through brain cancer you have to have
brain surgery mm-hmm to have a tumor
removed and oh by the way you're doing
everything else yeah that you do just to
try to stay afloat and you guys are
doing a documentary is that right yeah
well I was filming every step of the way
just to have it just to have it you know
the second I got diagnosed I flipped the
camera on me and Kevin we were in Mexico
and a parking lot and you're on vacation
no we had taken my mom in for treatment
we were taking her to alternative
treatments because they said her tumor
was growing I see and I found out once I
had checked them in it was a really
really bad time obviously when you find
out that this tumor is growing
I was really scary and then of course my
doctor was like I don't know how to tell
you this but you have one too and so I
flipped the camera on us and did like a
confessional and then from there I kept
filming everything different things
along the way the doctor appointments
and such and mainly so that I could
remember how I was acting how I felt
because it's easy to like kind of change
the story later like I want to remember
how I handled it right and that was
really important to me and and what I
was thinking and stuff and
my life moves so fast I forget totally
so i document everything anyway and so
when I was recovering from surgery our
CTO at afterbuzz and kevin strung all
the footage together excite a lot of it
and I had a lot of footage of my mom as
well and it was a little doc and so I
ended up connecting which oberlin jar
the goat of documentaries absolutely who
did Tony Robbins most recent one was it
the I am NOT your I'm not your guru yep
and he's done a ton of everything Ted
Bundy stuff yes didn't you do the West
Memphis Three yes yeah I mean he's
brilliant so I just had dinner with him
to ask him some advice and then I
started telling him my story of what I'd
been going through and he was like I I
want to work on this and so he was a
little busy with Ted Bundy at the time
so now we're connecting and we're gonna
figure out how to take it from where it
is and I don't want it to just be about
you know oh she had a brain tumor
everybody knows that we all know we've
got what we've been going through but I
want to show people kind of what gets
you there and I think it's more of like
a message to women that was Kevin who
had just this brilliant idea he does
Maria every speech you're going out and
talking to women you're telling them all
of these things that they need to hear
do it in the doc so that everybody can
hear it you know where as women were
everything to everyone and nothing to
ourselves we are so type-a we have to
make sure we get the flowers to somebody
on their birthday we got to make sure we
you know plan the vacation we're in
charge of like everything yeah and then
on top of it we have to make sure our
hair is diet and our nails are done and
we look amazing and somehow we can't age
and there's a lot of anxiety and there's
a lot that goes into being a woman and
we have to be perfect and we have to
balance it all no one ever asks a guy
how do they balance it all mm-hmm they
ask women every single day that's when
people go how do you balance at all I go
I have my wife do most of the stuff yeah
that's the way you do it yeah you guys
just in it's just a different thing and
so I want to
kind of show women and people in general
the new life perspectives I've had the
changes that I've made in my life so
that I can live a happier healthier life
I want people to focus on their health
more and to realize that you can do a
lot for a while
it eventually will catch up with you one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]